what's the like worst injury you've ever
had like like that hurt the most
the worst injury i've ever had do you
have one i remember once when i was a
kid i
we were playing tag or it as well
because brutal gaming
from barbarians and i was playing i was
uh
playing with my cousins and this one
time i ran like head
like i full on sprinted right uh and my
cousin was like standing next to a pole
and then i fell on sprinted to try and
get him and then i tripped and i like
face planted into this pole right and
like i i don't think i got any brain
damage or anything like that didn't get
a concussion but what i did get was this
like
tom and jerry type massive bump
on my head it was massive okay i i've
like to this like i've never seen
another injury like this where but like
my my
my forehead was just like this and the
entire
evening my parents were just spending
that like i was i was on my mom's lap
and she would have to like she had to
like literally
press it back in slowly over the course
of this entire night you should have
just been like it's my giga brain just
trying to like come out it's trying to
escape from my head
you know that you know that point where
you've you've got an injury you don't
know how bad it is
and then you see it and you're like oh
[ __ ] this is like way worse than i
thought it was initially oh yeah because
initially i'm like
yeah yeah yeah i'm good i'm good i can
handle this okay and then i saw myself
in the mirror
and then when i saw that massive lump
that's when like the wave of pain just
like came towards it so i don't know if
it was like a psychological thing
but it was probably the worst one i had
was uh i was out like camping with
friends because i always used to go
camping every year with my family and
like family friends
and like we were like maybe 10 years old
or something and
my friend and i were like just grabbing
rocks there was like this big cliff face
and we were just like kind of just
throwing rocks at the cliff because
what do you do what do you do when you
go camping right like
while the dads are sitting up to ten
we're like all right [ __ ] it let's just
sort of walk rocks or whatever
and one of the rocks uh had bounced like
my friend threw the rock against the
cliff
it bounced back and my hand was like
pressed up against like another
stone because i think i was sitting down
and the stone came back and just slammed
into my fingers
and i was like ow initially but then i
looked down and both of my fingernails
are just completely chipped off
oh and and like it was it was really
weird right it was kind of like your
thing where it's like
it hurts until you look at it and it's
like
oh now it really [ __ ] hurts that's so
gross
yeah so both of these fingernails were
gone for like a month maybe until they
like
re-grew back and uh yeah that was
probably the worst
yeah i think the most pain i've been in
i was like snowboarding
and i went you know
yeah it's just like oh god that's like
four years ago as well you know like
having some
uh like snow um [ __ ] what are they
ski resorts
yeah um they have some area that's like
designated for like tricks and do like
hot like there's like a half pack yeah
yeah yeah so i know i like going there
and i try to i normally can do like a
360 in the air
yeah okay like it's not clean stop
bragging
now i'm too scared to do it yeah because
one of them like i didn't go
off right and i just kind of like span
halfway and my back was facing so i was
up in the air maybe like i don't know
like i i landed in the bottom of the
the hot like the the ramp oh [ __ ] for
the next jump yeah it was just hard ice
yeah
and i must have been up in the air like
i don't know like three or four meters
off the ground right
just slammed on my back thought i broke
my back like i was so
winded i couldn't breathe because my
lungs had just been like
like [ __ ] pancakes yeah i was like
and they were like should we get the
like the ski ambulance i was like
broken the fall by like putting my hand
there as well so i sprained my wrist as
well yeah it was [ __ ] horrible yeah
yeah i've i've had a lot of snowboarding
and skiing
i had something similar like that but i
obviously wasn't in the air for
as long and also i always make sure
whenever i do do the jumps like i can do
like 180s and 360s as well
yeah i always make sure that the bottom
of it is like powder snow
just so if i [ __ ] up the landing then
it's just like a pillowy like
this feels nice sometimes you're like i
really want to do this sick jump but
there's no snow at the bottom but i'm
gonna [ __ ] do it
yeah moments before disaster yeah like
up and
up until that jump i was doing like one
eighty one i was like i'm gonna do the
big one
360. and then i went for it it just
completely failed and then i had to be
like dragged out of the way because
people are waiting to go as well it's
like a line system you know
yeah yeah they had to like drag me with
their skis on it's like oh my god it's
horrible